Esta es una implementación en JavaScript
de la función factorial usando recursividad
y memorización.
Vamos a revisarlo
para ver qué hace la computadora.
En primer lugar, tenemos la creación
de una estructura de datos memo, en este caso es
un objeto de JavaScript que vamos a llenar más
tarde luego vemos la definición de la función
factorial y entonces en la parte inferior lo
primero que hacemos es una invocación a la
función factorial de 2. Veamos qué pasa:
vamos a la función y vemos que 2 no es igual
a 0, así que esto es falso. El memo no tiene
un valor para 2, entonces esto también es falso.
Así que nos vamos al else y éste calcula invocando
recursivamente al factorial de n menos 1, entonces
invocará inmediatamente al factorial de 1,
y ahora estamos en la función cuando n es
igual a 1. Esto es falso, esto es falso,
así que vamos aquí y necesitamos calcular el
factorial de n 1 de nuevo, y esta vez será el
factorial de cero. Así que invoca de nuevo a la
función y ahora estamos en la función cuando n
es igual a 0, esta vez esta primera condición
es verdadera, así que la función va a regresar
un 1. Entonces nos regresa un 1 y ahora estamos
de vuelta en la función cuando n es igual a 1,
y ahora podemos actualizar el memo
y decir que memo de 1 es igual a 1.
Para que puedas ver que el objeto se actualiza
ahora tiene una llave con un valor. Devolvemos a
ese valor de 1 a quien lo llamó, así que ahora
estamos en la función cuando n es igual a 2,
y también tenemos un resultado para este.
Resultado es igual a 2, así que actualizamos
el memo de 2 para que sea igual a 2, y
regresamos resultado que es igual a 2.
Muy bien, entonces tenemos el factorial de 2
y ahora tenemos un memo que tiene dos llaves
para los valores de 1 y 2. Veamos qué sucede
cuando invocamos a factorial de 5. Entramos
en la función y 5 no es igual a cero, así que
esto es falso. El memo no tiene una llave de 5,
por lo que esto es falso. Así que vamos aquí
y queremos invocar a la función factorial
de n menos 1 que sería factorial de 4.
Inmediatamente hace eso y estamos en la
función para n igual a 4. No es igual a 0, no
está en el memo, así que vamos aquí y calcula
factorial de n menos 1 que es factorial de
3. Ahora estamos en factorial de n igual a 3.
3 no es igual a cero, el memo no tiene tres,
así que una vez más factorial de n menos 1
será factorial de dos. Aquí dos no es igual a
cero pero el memo tiene una propiedad para dos,
así que vamos a devolver el memo de dos,
que es igual a dos, y esta vez no tenemos
que invocar recursiva mente más funciones
porque ya sabemos la respuesta para dos.
Entonces esto regresa a cuando n es igual
a tres en la función factorial y ahora
tenemos que resultado es igual a 6, así que
podemos actualizar el memo para n igual a 3.
Luego volvemos a cuando n es igual a 4 en
factorial y ahora tenemos resultado igual a
24. Actualizamos el memo, volvemos a cuando n es
igual a 5. Tenemos que resultado es igual a 120.
Actualizamos el memo y lo regresamos. Entonces
puedes ver que ahorramos algunas invocaciones
recursivas allí porque ya teníamos el
factorial de 2 almacenado en el memo,
y si continuamos y llamamos a algo como
factorial de 10, también nos ahorraríamos
algunas invocaciones a la función porque ya
tenemos 5 factorial allí, y luego podría parar.